so
trick question for brady where does the
sun rise
the sun rises in the
east yes so that's the basic answer sun
rises in the east sets in the west and
it does that because we on earth are
the the earth is rotating in that
direction which makes the apparent
motion of the sun seem to crack across
the sky
but exactly where in the east the sun
rises uh depends very much on the time
of year and your latitude so i've set
this software up so that we are in
nottingham so hopefully you can see the
date down here which is set to the 21st
of june 2011. the time is 3 42 in the
morning which is why it's dark and we're
looking due east so we expect the sun to
rise somewhere in this vicinity we're
going to track through the sun's getting
the sky is getting lighter
and
bang there there the sun appears above
the horizon but it's not appearing due
east not at all
appearing quite a long way north of east
and that's that's the furthest north
that the sun is going to get this year
and to explain what's happening i can
actually put up a grid and this is the
projection of our longitudinal latitude
on the earth projected out onto the
celestial sphere if you look up up up
you can see
the projection of the north pole you can
see that the path the sun takes along
the sky certainly isn't in a straight up
and down direction it's following this
very long curved arc because it starts
so far north here on the longest day it
has this huge long arc that travels
across the sky
what i can actually do here though is
advance
uh through the year i'll go week by week
now
and we're gonna stay at the same time
every day so we're around about 9 30 and
you'll notice the sun is dramatically
changing its position
and in fact if we get all the way down
to december december 21st we get the
opposite effect we get the winter
solstice where the sun rises in at its
southern most southerly position so if i
swing around now we're looking due south
and again if i fast forward through one
day
you'll see here
the sun just barely arcs above the
horizon and that's why at northerly
latitudes as we are in in nottingham
we're at a latitude of 52 degrees
the winter days are very short
this is happening for the same reason we
have the seasons uh it's happening
because the earth's axis is tilted
towards and away from the sun by an
angle of 23 and a half degrees
so if the sun if the earth's axis wasn't
tilted we wouldn't have seasons at all
every day would be the same as the last
but because of this tilting in the
earth's axis some parts of the earth at
different times of year are bathed in
more sunlight than other parts of the
earth i guess the important thing for a
modern astronomer's point of view is
that the the solstice is the time of
year when the nights are shortest which
means that your working night is the
shortest
so actually some of us quite look
forward to the some of the summer
solstice because it means that when we
do go observing it means we only have to
observe for five or six hours rather
than the 12 or 13 hours you get if
you're observing in the middle of winter
sure you want the 13 hours though 13
hours is a very long time to be running
a telescope for so no actually i quite
enjoy the summer nights and also of
course the other benefit is summer
nights are much more likely to be clear
so not only do you have a short working
night but actually you're actually more
likely to get something productive out
of it as well
so let's take another look at the sun's
path through the sky throughout the year
you could make the same effect by going
outside your house and taking a picture
of the rising sun or the sun at any time
of day as long as it was the same time
of day every year
and as we fast forward through
first one year
and now another year
week by week you see this very
distinctive pattern building up this
figure of eight
and this is called an analemna this is
the the path that the sun takes
throughout the year and if we look at
the top of the analemna
and now i'll advance day by day you see
that the position of the sun the sun's
motion seems to slow down and almost
stop
the point at which it stops is the
solstice so the word solstice comes from
the latin soul which is sun and sistera
which is to stand still so the sun
obviously isn't actually standing still
but as we look at it day by day its
transition in a northerly and southerly
direction
seems to pause turn around and head in
the other direction at each end is the
solstice and at the middle
happens twice a year
september 21st and march 21st is the
equinox that's the other important point
in the annual calendar with respect to
the sun's motion through the earth so at
the equinox if we reverse back to
sunrise on this day september 21st
we'll find that boom
the sun now rises due east so on two
days of the year no matter where you are
on earth the sun will rise exactly due
east and set exactly due west i guess
it's it's sort of buried deep in
people's consciousness because
back in the days when you know we were
agricultural societies and understanding
what the seasons were doing was sort of
vitally important to us um then clearly
it was a big deal because you needed to
know where you were in that cycle to
know what to do with your crops and so
on so i guess at some very sort of deep
level it's embedded on this
the importance of these things and
clearly you know christmas for example
you know probably the biggest ceremony
of the year is fundamentally about the
solstice you know it's sort of been
adopted by the christian church but they
really just borrowed the winter solstice
um
for the for the celebration so it
clearly is even even today it's sort of
deeply embedded in our culture the
behavior of the sun that we see depends
very much on where we are on earth
so we can for example take a trip with
this software up to the north pole so of
course
at the summer solstice on the north pole
the north pole is head is tilted
directly towards the sun it's going to
be bathed in perpetual sunlight all day
there's going to be no sunrise and no
sunset so what do you think happens to
the sun
now the north pole at the 21st of june
if we fast forward through a day now
the sun will just appear
to rotate
around the horizon at the same altitude
no sunrise no sunset
whereas
if we visit the equinox here so back at
september 21st
the sun sun's just going to cruise right
round the horizon for the entire day
that's the last you're going to see of
the sun for six months because the next
day it's going to dip down below the
horizon and it's going to stay there
until the next equinox where it
reappears and moves its way above the
horizon
if we look at a globe
old-fashioned globes you may have
noticed
a couple of dots of of lines marked on
there one is the tropic of cancer in the
north and one is the tropic of capricorn
in the south and that's the latitude at
which the sun is directly overhead
on the summer solstice
so here in nottingham the sun actually
never gets directly overhead
it's always sort of tilted with respect
to the horizon but between these two
lines of latitude somewhat at some point
during the year the sun will be directly
overhead
now that's an interesting little factoid
but two thousand years ago it led to a
greek astronomer calculating very simply
the circumference of the earth
so the reason he was able to do this was
that he discussed this was
eratosthenes and he
was in ancient egypt
and he discovered in a manuscript a
description of a town called
siren i think which was located on the
tropic of cancer and there was a special
feature about this town that was that
was noted down
on the summer solstice the sun would
shine directly down a particular well
there and not cast a shadow
and he was a very clever man and he
realized that this wasn't the same
behavior that was exhibited
at alexandria where he was some distance
to the north on the summers at the
summer solstice a stick or a well in the
ground would actually cast a shadow
so he
made a measurement on the summer
solstice of this shadow located in
alexandria and came up with a
measurement of seven and a half degrees
and he he figured he thought like many
ancient greeks that the earth was round
and he sought okay seven and a half
degrees
is approximately one fiftieth of 360
degrees a full circle
therefore the distance between
alexandria and siren
must be one fiftieth of the
circumference of the earth
according to the story he then paid
someone to march out and measure the
distance between those two cities
two towns
and he actually came up with a
calculation of the circumference of the
earth that was good to within about four
percent which was pretty impressive all
from measuring a few angles and a and a
distance and knowing a bit about how the
sun moved around the sky and he didn't
have one of those things to do and he
did not have one of these things to do
it now
so interestingly the traffic of cancer
was so named because several thousand
years ago when they named it the sun was
actually in the constellation of cancer
that's no longer the case now because
the earth's axis precesses
it sort of wobbles like a spinning top
on the summer solstice the sun is
actually in the constellation of taurus
well all of this is happening because if
you are the sun brady the earth is
tilted at 23 degrees towards you and so
it's rotating which is causing a day but
it's also moving around you which is
causing the year
so at the summer solstice
in the northern hemisphere
the the north pole is pointing towards
the sun at the what we call the winter
solstice but of course you would
probably call the summer solstice being
from the southern hemisphere the south
pole is tilted towards the sun and the
sun and the earth is still rotating like
this well we're reasonably close to
upright in fact most of the planets are
sort of reasonably close to upright
which presumably does indeed reflect the
fact that the solar system did all form
from the single spinning disc and the
planets sort of remember about that spin
and so spin more or less the same way
but of course various things have gone
on since the planets formed um so for
example it's thought that the way the
moon was formed was by something fairly
large smashing into the earth and
knocking a chunk of the earth out and
obviously the direction in which that
impact occurred could well have tipped
the axis one way or the other so
although the planets sort of remember
how the solar system formed in that
their axis tend to be pointed more or
less the same they seem to have the same
kind of spin as the solar system they
all have had sort of subsequent history
which has knocked them about a bit so
for thousands of years not to go over
the top but astronomy was one of the
first and most fundamental sciences
imagine the power that astronomers had
being able to predict uh the the times
of the seasons when the sun would arise
solar eclipses that sort of thing and
you can see this in civilizations around
the world people building gigantic
monuments or kinds of observatories that
would actually track and help calculate
these things so case in point of course
one very famous one in the uk is
stonehenge and stonehenge is very famous
at the summer
because the people who built it
knew exactly where on the horizon on
that particular day the sun was going to
rise
and so they built it so that if you're
standing in the center looking out the
entrance you'll see the sun rising at a
particular point